remember last year we spoke about a
story of a of a woman who uh is stuck in
a body that is younger oh I knew I knew
that you had something yeah thank you
thank you you [__] had something
this is awesome yeah this is awesome I
love this this story is I can't believe
you started with M Ms this story I had a
joke I had a joke oh that was awesome oh
yeah yeah the story was just a joke for
your outfit
yeah okay it worked it was a good job
okay
this store right here oh my God miles
please please say because I still don't
know what the [__] you're talking about
last year we talked about it
last year we talked about a woman uh who
is 23 I think she might have been 22 at
the time and she is stuck in what some
would say is the body of an
eight-year-old have you stuck in an
eight year old yeah we talked about this
like a year ago when the documentary
came out or whatever and yeah she uh we
spoke about this when we had some hot
takes at the time and one of the hot
takes might have been about her dating
and like what's the controversy on that
what's the what's it about and now she
apparently has a boyfriend who is 23 23
years old
a full male body also full male body
looks like a dude 26 year old man oh 26
she's 23. yeah oh she's 23. look at that
she's right there hey no no hey yo nah
you at the restaurant you see them
talking holding hands kiss what do you
do you gotta snuff that guy right you
gotta
because if you're a pedophile
this is not illegal wait does he he
doesn't win
he's a pedophile clearly but he's not
having sex with children oh good so like
this is like a methadone uh yeah I mean
you found that outlet for his his
Affliction yeah and if he's not a
pedophile he's a [__] [__] for
taking up the spot yeah true like think
about that but think how many kids are
safer because this guy is with a grown
not grown person yeah I mean
or just an absolute psychopath he is but
he's finding the healthiest way to be
that yeah he is I'll give you that
but what is her option is she's supposed
to be alone for the rest of her life
[Music]
she can't
what tell me I'm wrong you're wrong
you're wrong
[Music]
I can't have both wait a minute it can't
be wrong if she dates a girl or
something audience I just want to just
give our costume a second it can't be
wrong if she dates a grown-up man and
then also wrong if she dates a younger
person can I throw a thing at you oh
[__] I wasn't prepared okay go ahead
it's not wrong for her to date the man
it's wrong for the man to date her
because that means he's into but if we
make it let me just get the whole thing
out but if he because he's into things
that look eight years old she's 23 in
her mind she's supposed to be in to
[__] yeah that are old so she's
not doing anything wrong he's doing
something wrong if she's dating other
kids I mean she's also into youngins but
if we make it disgusting for any grown
man to date her yeah what is she to do
she just dies alone forever because we
as anxiety shame the man who's finding a
healthy outlet for his pygmy mental
illness pygmy what's that I don't know
what that means go to Congo
data Pig me
atballs
I mean she got options she could pass
that [__] like Stockton this is a lyric
for Jack Harlow no but I need to hit my
mind when Lucy does it it's whack when I
do it is I mean whatever yeah
no I'm saying pick me the pygmies are
these small people that are in the
jungle in Congo but do they look young
if she dates a small person can the mini
me do the one that was in Austin Powers
he's dead rip oh yeah yeah
I think you understand the question
that's being asked
come on let him cook
Bros
it was good
that was cute I didn't know but we all
know you know where we're saying we
don't have to name specific names a
little person yeah any little person
random yeah 30 years old single yeah
dates this girl is he wrong
no
so it's okay as long as you're not
you know over five feet or whatever
because you're saying it's wrong for
this guy yeah it's still weird even if
it's a low person yeah
looks like a child as well boom done
he also has a child disease yes that's
the only people child disease could do
it yeah that's fair otherwise they're
just gonna get crazy looks and you're
gonna have to explain to every single
person yo she's actually 23 and no one
would really believe that like
the thing that she should do is she's
already started it but she should be
covered with [__] tattoos like
sleeved up like the whole thing and then
people be like oh maybe she's a little
person or something because
eight-year-olds usually don't got full
sleeves God that's actually that sounds
like a good ass idea and she's begun it
already I imagine that's like part of it
but that's crazy
what's wrong with all you
regular size [__] I can't find a man
bro
this guy's a piece too
so far I'm Googling around I don't know
if it's confirmed confirmed that they're
dating dating no I mean that in and of
itself is a lot right there like you
don't even take a picture with that
apparently I think he might be like
producing her show or something like
that so like but it's like rumor that
they're dating
uh so yeah it's uh I mean that's a lot
for him yeah but how you think it is
though I don't even never mind
how you doing all right what do you mean
how do you think what is
what that's yeah I think no but like
what do you think you're weird
thinking about the grip
no nah you was thinking
no how does she paddle boys
it's probably easier for everyone that's
wild yo it is really peculiar you would
be thinking about her grip he's gotta
wait for her after he's paddleboarding
because he's gonna pass
himself
we talk about you talking about the grip
but I've never thought about the grip
you would definitely why are you
bringing it up why are you even bringing
that up I didn't say but I bet it looked
like a thimble
foreign
[Laughter]
he is smiling bro
micro
paddle boarding the whole time no he was
not you were talking about different you
were talking about something very
different right now hey
no no
she's doing but Mark stop it bro
no [__] new [__] no no no no no no no no
no no you was trying to look at how big
that 23 year old you're being weird stop
looking at you stop looking through
pictures this is weird
I said paddleboarding
you've got everyone else made a weird
he's just looking for somebody for her
to tag another one so that he could go
it's like do you have any other little
[__] how old is she 23 bro she getting
drunk is she getting [__] up bro no no
come on you was thinking about the grip
he is like 23 in here
can you be honest you were thinking
about the grip no I was not I don't
think sexually with this like I'm like
okay maybe a day go home watch CoCo milk
I'm not thinking in like a weird way
you're going home with her after the
date what if I'm babysitting I don't
know first thought is going home he
really thought about taking it talk
about the exact Netflix and chill he
would queue up ain't that crazy what do
you mean you was gonna watch Kitty stuff
she's 23 years old and you think about
the grip so why you guys all being weird
when you're talking about why are you
trying to make her a kid make her watch
CoCo melon live out your fans that's a
good show God
symbol really a thimble I don't think
it's a symbol
what why wait wait wait wait wait why is
that so crazy son that's crazy bro but
what is so crazy about it what are you
thinking about it what do you think it
looks like just you don't think you
don't think it's a little penne all
about
oh my God
it's crazy
why are you wash it out before you get
[__] hard
[__] goofy you're getting a boner
talking about that little 23 year old
eight-year-old
son you need to stop him
who even said that we're not talking
about [__] we talking about his
little pigtail of a dick
[Laughter]
come on
that's what he says come on yo come on
man switch 23 what's the next one 23rd
hey you think it's weird to talk about
that 23 year old human why did Miles
bring it up that's my question why would
he even
don't do that why were you thinking
about it yeah what do you think about it
I thought it was an interesting topic
that we talked about once before and I
thought I'd bring it back up for the
podcast great training or you say you
want to have her in your house
bro
he's like he's like I think I could
crate trainer in about two to three
months if I had her in my house
I said you live in Brooklyn Heights damn
the last place you see
damn miles yeah so don't do that
that was very inappropriate duh
what do you think about whoever what do
you think about the girl
oh sorry I was looking
at what emails what are you guys talking
about what do you mean what are we
talking about that Little Rock
what do you mean did she catch a little
Alfalfa up okay
okay listen miles you've been killing us
so far
in our careers from your heart yes
indeed baby you had a 28 year old
you killed it and it was very
entertaining that was great I I have so
much confidence in you to run that [__]
back